This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The date September 11th is of course very significant for people in the US, but the country of Chile also has an important September 11th in their history. On 9-11, 1973, using both airstrikes and ground attacks, a military junta violently took control of Chile. The country was led at the time by President Salvador Ayernde. Producer Katie Mingle Ayernde had become president of Chile in a free and democratic election. After the military coup, General Augusto Pinochet took power and ruled Chile as a dictator until 1990.
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。9月11日这个日期对美国人来说当然意义重大，但智利的历史上也有一个重要的9月11日。在1973年9月11日，智利军方通过空袭和地面进攻，以暴力手段夺取了政权。当时的智利国家元首是萨尔瓦多·阿连德总统。制作人凯蒂·明格尔：阿连德是通过自由民主的选举当选智利总统的。军事政变后，奥古斯都·皮诺切特将军夺取政权，并作为独裁者统治智利直到1990年。
After taking over the country, the military dissolved Congress, took control of the media, and went about dismantling all of the socialist and democratic institutions that Ianday's government had built. And somewhere in the midst of all of this, the new military regime discovered something in a non-descript office building in downtown Santiago. It was a room, a very strange room. I've heard people compare it to something out of a Kubrick film, a star track. That's Eden Medina, a professor of informatics and computing at Indiana University in Bloomington describing this strange place. It's quite striking.
接管国家后，军方解散了国会，接手控制了媒体，并着手拆解阿连德政府建立的所有社会主义和民主机构。就在这一切发生的混乱之中，新的军政府在圣地亚哥市中心一栋不起眼的办公大楼里发现了一样东西。那是一个房间，一个非常奇怪的房间。我听说有人把它比作库布里克电影或《星际迷航》里的场景。那是印第安纳大学布卢明顿分校的信息学和计算教授伊登·梅迪纳，她在描述这个奇怪的地方。这非常引人注目。
It's in this bright, technicaler. Aranges, wood paneling. Picture the deck of the Starship Enterprise, and you're not that far off. The room was hexagonal in shape, with seven white fiberglass chairs arranged in an inward-facing circle. There were colorful, space-agie screens
它在一个明亮、具有科技感的房间里。橙色的色调，木质镶板。想象一下“星舰企业号”的舰桥，你离那个画面就不远了。这个房间呈六边形，里面有七张白色的玻璃钢椅子，排成一个向内的圆圈。到处都是色彩斑斓、具有太空时代感的屏幕
displaying charts and graphs on all six walls. When Pinotier's men found this room, they didn't quite know what to make of it. It's said that one of them began stabbing its colorful display screens with a knife. And it's no wonder they didn't understand this place. There had never been anything quite like it. This operations room was the physical interface for a complicated system called Project Cybersen. Project Cybersen had been designed to help Chile's socialist experiment work better. It was just one of the ways that former President Ayende had been trying to do socialism differently than it had ever been done before. So let's back up before the coup, before this sci-fi operations room was built.
六面墙上都显示着图表和曲线图。当皮诺切特的手下发现这个房间时，他们完全不知道该怎么处理它。据说其中一人开始用刀刺向那些色彩斑斓的显示屏。他们不理解这个地方也并不奇怪。此前从来没有过类似的东西。这个作战室是一个名为“赛博信计划”的复杂系统的物理界面。赛博信计划旨在帮助智利的社会主义实验运作得更好。这只是前总统阿连德试图以一种前所未有的方式推行社会主义的方法之一。让我们回到政变之前，回到这个科幻作战室建造之前。
Salvador Ayende had been elected in 1970. He was the first Marxist president ever elected democratically in any country. That's his campaign song you're hearing right now. It's called Ben Ceremos, or We Shall Overcome. Written by the Ben, Kiela Paiyun, it was one of many protest songs and chance to come out of A Yanday's campaign. Poor and working class people sang,
萨尔瓦多·阿连德于1970年当选。他是通过民主选举产生的历史上第一位马克思主义总统。你现在听到的就是他的竞选歌曲。它叫《Venceremos》，意为“我们会胜利”。由安赫尔·帕拉创作，它是阿连德竞选中涌现出的众多抗议歌曲和口号之一。贫困和工人阶级的民众高唱着
enchanted, and finally voted A Iyendae, into office. They loved him. And Iyendae hoped he could show the world that Chile was going to be different than the communist and socialist experiments in other countries. His government, after all, had been elected democratically, and it was deeply committed to protecting civil liberties. So it did not want to get rid of the Constitution, it did not want to censor the press,
充满激情，最终投票将阿连德送上了总统宝座。他们爱戴他。阿连德希望他能向世界证明，智利将不同于其他国家的共产主义和社会主义实验。毕竟，他的政府是通过民主选举产生的，并且坚定致力于保护公民自由。因此，它不想废除宪法，不想审查新闻，
it wanted to preserve freedom of speech. And right away the government raises employment and wages for people across Chile, and they start a program of agrarian reform to redistribute the ownership of land. And they also began a program to make consumer goods that previously had been reserved for the elite to try to make them more broadly accessible to the Chilean people. Toward this end, Iandai formed an industrial design group in his government. He believed design
它想要维护言论自由。政府上台后立即提高了智利各地人民的就业率和工资，并启动了一项土地改革计划，重新分配土地所有权。他们还启动了一项计划，生产以前专属于精英阶层的消费品，试图让智利人民更广泛地获得这些商品。为此，阿连德在他的政府中成立了一个工业设计小组。他相信设计
was political. We were thinking that we were doing something great, good for people and good for humanity. That's for Nando Flores. He began working in the Ayende government after the election. And he says to say it was an exciting time as an understatement. It wasn't just excitement, it was like being in love. If you have a lovely songwanda, you are thinking the 24 hours a day. We were working in a big, big adventure, but the whole country was an adventure for those people that believe in agenda. The whole country was an adventure for those that believed in a Yende, an adventure, but also a ton of work.
具有政治性。我们当时认为自己在做一件伟大的事，对人民好，对人类好。那是费尔南多·弗洛雷斯。他在选举后开始在阿连德政府中工作。他说，用“激动人心”来形容那段时期都算是轻描淡写了。那不仅仅是兴奋，那种感觉就像是坠入爱河。如果你有一首动听的歌曲，你会一天24小时都在想它。我们是在进行一场巨大无比的冒险，但对于那些信仰阿连德的人来说，整个国家就是一场冒险。对于那些信仰阿连德的人来说，整个国家就是一场冒险，这是一场冒险，但也是繁重的工作。
So the central problem is a central problem in socialist revolutions, which is the government must go about turning all the private businesses into public businesses. Just think about the challenge of bringing the most important industries in your country under state control and not having the experience to do so. The government eventually took control of 150 enterprises, including several of the largest companies in Chile. And this is the not so fun part of a socialist revolution, management.
所以核心问题是社会主义革命中的一个核心问题，那就是政府必须把所有私营企业变成公有制企业。试想一下，在没有相关经验的情况下，将国内最重要的工业置于国家控制之下，这是一项多么巨大的挑战。政府最终控制了150家企业，其中包括智利几家最大的公司。这就是社会主义革命中不那么有趣的部分：管理。
Oh, people are doing political revolution, they don't care about management, but I care. Fernando Flores cared about management. And he had an idea for how to manage Chile's complicated economy. He wanted to use a relatively new science called cybernetics. Cybernetics is a science that became popular around World War II. As humans develop new kinds of machines, we became interested in developing systems for
哦，人们在进行政治革命时，根本不在乎管理，但我很在乎。费尔南多·弗洛雷斯关心管理。他有一个想法，关于如何管理智利复杂的经济。他想利用一门相对较新的科学——控制论。控制论是二战前后流行起来的一门科学。随着人类开发出各种新型机器，我们开始对开发控制
controlling those machines. Cybernetics looks at how to design intelligent, self-correcting systems. Cybernetics is based on the word, cyberneties, which is Greek for Steersman. The goal of a Steersman is to get the ship to the destination, taking into account all kinds of feedback from the environment,
这些机器的系统产生兴趣。控制论研究如何设计智能的、自我纠正的系统。控制论（Cybernetics）这个词源于希腊语“Kubernetes”，意思是舵手。舵手的目标是让船到达目的地，同时考虑到来自环境的各种反馈，
like wind and currents. All cybernetics systems have goals. So you can think about the heating and cooling system in your home as a cybernetic system. The goal is to keep your house at a desired temperature. The thermostat does this by telling the heater or the air conditioner when to turn on and off depending on feedback it's receiving from the environment. It's an intelligent self-regulating system with a goal. In England in the 1960s, a consultant named Stafford Beer was applying concepts of cybernetics to business management.
比如风和洋流。所有的控制论系统都有目标。所以你可以把家里的冷暖系统看作是一个控制论系统。它的目标是把你的房子保持在期望的温度。恒温器通过根据从环境中收到的反馈来告诉加热器或空调何时开启和关闭，从而实现这一点。这是一个具有目标的智能自主调节系统。在20世纪60年代的英国，一位名叫斯塔福德·比尔的顾问将控制论的概念应用于企业管理。
He believed a business could be thought of as an intelligent system. If the goal was to sell more product or work more efficiently, you could, using the principles of cybernetics, design the system to work toward those goals. But Stafford Beer had never imagined he'd get to apply his ideas to helping a whole government succeed. And then I suddenly got a letter which very much changed my life. It was from the technical general manager of the state planning board of Chile.
他认为企业可以被视为一个智能系统。如果目标是销售更多产品或提高工作效率，利用控制论的原则，你就可以将系统设计为朝着这些目标运作。但斯塔福德·比尔从未想过自己有机会将这些想法应用到帮助整个政府走向成功上。然后我突然收到了一封信，这极大地改变了我的一生。信来自智利国家计划委员会的技术总经理。
That Stafford Beer in archival tape from 1974, the letter he got was from Fernando Flores. He remarked in this letter that he had studied all my works. He had collected a team of scientists together, and would I please come and take it over. But this was to start me on a journey, which made me travel 8,000 miles over and over and over again. I was commuting between London and Santiago for two years.
那是1974年档案录音中的斯塔福德·比尔，他收到的那封信来自费尔南多·弗洛雷斯。他在信中提到他研究了我所有的著作。他召集了一支科学家团队，问我是否愿意去接管它。但这让我踏上了一段旅程，让我一次又一次地旅行了8000英里。我在伦敦和圣地亚哥之间通勤了两年。
Stafford Biers' first trip to Santiago was in 1971. When he arrived, he and Fernando Flores and the team they had assembled in Chile went about designing a cybernetics system that could help them manage the bureaucracy of the new Chilean economy. They would call this project Cybersen. Stafford Beer had long stringy hair and a long beard. He looked like he should be leading yoga retreats, not teaching major corporations about management.
斯塔福德·比尔第一次去圣地亚哥是在1971年。他到达后，与费尔南多·弗洛雷斯以及他们在智利组建的团队一起，着手设计一个控制论系统，以帮助他们管理新智利经济的官僚体制。他们将这个项目命名为“赛博信计划”。斯塔福德·比尔留着长长的直发和大胡子。他看起来应该去领导瑜伽静修，而不是向大公司教授管理学。
Beer was particularly interested in using cybernetics to help companies redistribute power within the system, and Chile was interested in this too. How do we make institutions non-hierarchical? How do we distribute decision-making? The first thing beer did was map and model Chile's entire economy. This was a really complex process that involved understanding how each part of the economy was affected by other parts and by outside feedback. On paper, it looks like a big block diagram connected with lines and arrows. Now we have the economy. These are the big major branches of industry, heavy industry, light industry, materials industry, and consumer industry.
比尔尤其对利用控制论来帮助公司重新分配系统内的权力感兴趣，智利对此也很感兴趣。我们如何使机构去官僚化、去中心化？我们如何分配决策权？比尔做的第一件事就是绘制并建模智利的整个经济。这是一个非常复杂的过程，涉及到理解经济的每个部分如何受到其他部分以及外部反馈的影响。在纸上，它看起来像一个用线条和箭头连接的大型方框图。现在我们有了经济。这些是工业的大支柱，重工业、轻工业、材料工业和消费品工业。
It wasn't enough, however, to just understand how all the parts of Chile's economy connected. It was also crucial that the different parts be able to communicate with each other. Beer wanted factories to be able to send and receive information. He wanted to create a vast computer network that connected all the factories in Chile. Which was a really novel idea. This was pre-internet. Computer networks weren't really a thing yet. But there was a problem with this idea.
然而，仅仅了解智利经济各部分是如何连接的是不够的。至关重要的是，不同部分之间能够相互通信。比尔希望工厂能够发送和接收信息。他希望创建一个连接智利所有工厂的庞大计算机网络。这是一个非常新颖的想法。这是在互联网出现之前。计算机网络当时还算不上什么普遍存在的事物。但这个想法有一个问题。
There were only a handful of computers in all of Chile. And beer, he only had access to one of them. These guys, they had to create a computer network using one computer, which is pretty amazing. So, they improvised. They realized, okay, we can't put computers throughout the country, but what we can do is we have these TELX machines. A TELX machine looks like a typewriter, but it's hooked up to a telephone line. So imagine you and your friend you both have Telix machines. You can type a message on the keyboard,
整个智利只有少数几台计算机。而比尔，他只能使用其中的一台。这些家伙不得不只用一台计算机来创建一个计算机网络，这真是太了不起了。所以，他们即兴发挥。他们意识到，好吧，我们不能在全国各地都部署计算机，但我们能做到的是，我们有这些电传打字机。电传打字机看起来像一台打字机，但它连接着一条电话线。所以想象一下你和你的朋友都有电传打字机。你可以在键盘上打一条消息，
he hits send, and your friend's Telix will receive it, and literally type it out onto a piece of paper. It's like super steampunk G-Chat. I think G-Chat is a great way to think about it. Every day, someone from a factory would send data via Telix to another Telix, where it would be received by an operator and then entered into the central computer. The kinds of data that people might send could include raw materials. How much cotton do you have?
他点击发送，你朋友的电传机就会收到它，并 literalmente（字面意义上）把它打印在纸上。这就像是超级蒸汽朋克版的谷歌聊天。我认为谷歌聊天是一个很好的比喻。每天，工厂里的某个人都会通过电传机向另一个电传机发送数据，数据会被操作员接收，然后输入到中央计算机中。人们可能发送的数据种类包括原材料。你有多少棉花？
How much coal do you have? The Central Computer Software Program, Cyberstried, was able to analyze the data and warn about potential problems. This is what your worker absentee level was today. This is what it was the day before. This is what it was the day before that. What is it going to be tomorrow? Are you going to have a problem? Decisions could then be made about what to do. And this brings us back to that bizarre hexagonal room, the one that looks like something out of a Kubrick film,
你有多少煤炭？中央计算机软件程序“Cyberstride”能够分析数据并发出潜在问题的警告。这就是你今天的工人旷工水平。这是前一天的水平。这是前天之前的水平。明天会怎样？你们会遇到问题吗？然后就可以就是否采取行动做出决策。这就把我们带回了那个奇异的六边形房间，那个看起来像是出自库布里克电影的房间，
or Star Trek. So the operations room, it is a futuristic decision-making space. Stafford Beer wanted to build a physical space for Project Cyberson. Actually, he wanted to build several of them, all over Chile, but only one was ever finished. The room was inspired in part by Winston Churchill's several of them, all over Chile, but only one was ever finished. The room was inspired in part by Winston Churchill's War Room, so you can imagine the
或者是《星际迷航》。所以这个作战室是一个具有未来感的决策空间。斯塔福德·比尔想为“赛博信计划”建造一个实体空间。事实上，他想在智利各地建造好几个这样的房间，但最终只有一个建成了。这个房间的设计部分灵感来源于温斯顿·丘吉尔的作战室，所以你可以想象
general sitting around smoking their cigars, or in this case, the Chilean sitting around smoking cigarettes and perhaps drinking Pisco Sowers. But unlike Churchill's War Room, and this is a key difference, this was a room for non-hierarchical decision making. war room. And this is a key difference. This was a room for non-hierarchical decision-making. Stafford Beer imagined factory workers and high-level bureaucrats alike, making decisions together. I asked him, look, do you really need a design for this? I mean, you take some tables, it does just. Their projector is there, so what? That's Gui Bansiappe. Originally from Germany, Bansiappe had been working in Chile's industrial design
将军们坐在一起抽着雪茄，或者在这个案例中，智利人坐在一起抽着烟，也许还喝着皮斯科酸酒。但与丘吉尔的作战室不同的是——这是一个关键区别——这是一个用于非等级化决策的房间。作战室。而这是一个关键区别。这是一个用于非等级化决策的房间。斯塔福德·比尔想象着工厂工人和高级官僚们聚在一起，共同做出决策。我问他，听着，你真的需要为这个做设计吗？我的意思是，你搬几张桌子，不就行了吗。投影仪在那里，那又怎样？那是吉·邦西佩。邦西佩原籍德国，曾在智利工业设计小组工作，
group and was busy designing cool products for the masses when he was tapped to help design the operations room for Project Cybersen. Eventually he realized Stafford Beer wanted the room to be so much more than a standard meeting room. During the project I became more and more aware of the complexity and the ambition of this project. It is the interface which made it possible for the users to use the system. The room needed to be democratic instead of the art. And please, no tables.
正忙着为大众设计炫酷的产品，当时他被选中协助设计“赛博信计划”的作战室。最终他意识到，斯塔福德·比尔希望这个房间远不止是一个标准的会议室。在项目进行过程中，我越来越意识到这个项目的复杂性和宏大抱负。它是让用户能够使用系统的界面。这个房间需要是民主的，而不是高高在上的。请千万不要放桌子。
No table because Stafford Bierset, look, this is a room for making decisions not for reading reports and talking about notes. So he was very categorically about this. The room was designed to quickly convey information about factories all over Chile. You have charts and graphs of factory production on the walls. You have a photograph of the factory that is discussed. You have flashing lights that show whether there are emergencies taking place. Seven people would sit in a circle discussing and deciding how to proceed with various problems.
不要桌子，因为斯塔福德·比尔说，听着，这是一个用来做决策的房间，而不是用来读报告和讨论笔记的。所以他在这方面非常绝对。这个房间旨在快速传达关于智利全国各地工厂的信息。墙上有工厂生产的图表和曲线图。有正在讨论的工厂的照片。有闪烁的灯光，显示是否发生了紧急情况。七个人围坐成一个圈，讨论并决定如何处理各种问题。
Seven, because it's an odd number to facilitate voting in a circle so that no one would be prioritized over anyone else, so it's not a rectangular table with a head. Each chair in the operations room had a place to set your whiskey glass, an ass tray, and a set of buttons one could use to control the display screens on each wall. It's madmen meets Star Trek. Though Bonziet Bayton says they weren't consciously trying to make it look futuristic. Certainly was not our idea,
数字七是因为它是一个奇数，便于在圆圈中进行投票，这样就不会有人凌驾于其他人之上，所以它不是那种带有主位的长方形桌子。作战室里的每张椅子上都有一个放威士忌杯的地方、一个烟灰缸，以及一组可以用来控制每面墙上显示屏的按钮。这是《广告狂人》与《星际迷航》的结合。尽管邦西佩说他们并不是刻意让它看起来具有未来感。这当然不是我们的主意，
or we didn't make science fiction. We made science reality, which is some different, I would say. But to me, there is a bit of fiction in all of it. It's an immaculate piece of design, but it can seal a clunky technology. The buttons on the chairs, for instance, were connected to some wires that ran under the floor and behind the wall and eventually connected to three slide caracels. And depending on the combination of buttons that you pushed, it would advance one slide carousel or another
或者我们不是在做科幻。我们创造的是科幻现实，我想这有所不同。但在我看来，这一切中都有一点虚构的成分。这是一件无可挑剔的设计作品，但它掩盖了笨拙的技术。例如，椅子上的按钮连接着一些电线，这些电线穿过地板下方和墙壁后面，最终连接到三个幻灯片旋转盘。根据你按下的按钮组合，它会推进一个或另一个幻灯片旋转盘，
or tell the slide carousel to move backwards as a way to pull up the desired image. These screens couldn't display information in real time. You could only display and discuss slides that had been pre-made. So it's this image of modernity, but behind it there's just a lot of human labor going into to making this illusion possible. While Project Cyberson was coming together and the futuristic operations room was being designed and built, things were not going so well
或者让幻灯片旋转盘倒退，以此来调出想要的图像。这些屏幕无法实时显示信息。你只能展示和讨论那些预先制作好的幻灯片。所以这是一种现代性的形象，但在它背后，其实有大量的人力劳动在支撑着这种幻象的实现。正当“赛博信计划”逐步成型、未来主义作战室的设计和建造都在进行时，阿连德政府的情况却并不那么顺利。
for the Yende government. So all of this is taking place during the heart of the Cold War, and Latin America has emerged as a battlefield. The US had been actively working with people within Chile who were unhappy with the government. So the US was intervening in Chile in many, many, many different ways so that the AND government would fail.
所以这一切都发生在冷战最核心的时期，拉丁美洲已经成为了一个战场。美国一直在积极与智利国内对政府不满的人进行合作。因此，美国在许多、许多、许多不同的方面干预智利，以便让阿连德政府失败。
They had been involved in denying Chile's foreign credit. It became increasingly difficult for Chileans to get a hold of US spare parts to US machinery. If you don't have the parts, you can't keep the machines running. The economy was collapsing. Inflation had started to skyrocket, so people are having trouble getting basic items. And then just three years after Ayende was elected, came Chile's September 11th. September 11th? So, in history? Well, I don't want to talk about that. I, for me, is a very dramatic day. It brings memories. That's for non-ando Flores again.
他们参与了拒绝向智利提供外国信贷的行动。智利人越来越难以买到美国机械的备用零件。如果你没有零件，你就无法让机器继续运转。经济正在崩溃。通货膨胀开始飙升，所以人们很难买到基本物品。就在阿连德当选三年后，智利的“9月11日”来临了。9月11日？所以在历史上？嗯，我不想谈这个。对我来说，这是非常戏剧性的一天。它唤起了回忆。那是费尔南多·弗洛雷斯又一次说道。
I was with the palace, with the press conference and some other people. We were as flooded, we were bombed by planes. While the presidential palace was bombed by a military junta supported by the United States, I end day gave his final radio address to the country. Long live Chile, long live the people, long live the workers he is saying. These have been my last words and I'm certain that my sacrifice will not be in vain. I'm certain that at the very least it will be a lesson that will punish felons, cowardice and treason.
我和（总统府）的人在一起，正在开记者会和其他一些人在一起。我们遭到了轰炸，我们遭到了飞机的轰炸。当总统府遭到美国支持的军政府轰炸时，阿连德发表了他对全国的最后一次广播讲话。智利万岁，人民万岁，工人万岁，他这样说道。这些将是我的最后遗言，我确信我的牺牲不会白费。我确信，它至少会成为一个教训，去惩罚叛国、懦弱和背叛。
Those explosions were recorded in the actual radio broadcast. Salvador Añende took his own life that same day, shortly after giving that address. It's estimated that during Pinachet's rule, about 38,000 people were imprisoned, and most of those prisoners were tortured. Close to 3,000 people were executed. Another 1,200 people went missing, and around 200,000 people were exiled to other countries. In fact, Kiela Paiun, the band that wrote Allende's campaign song, was exiled to other countries. In fact, Kila Pallune, the band that wrote Ayandes' campaign song, was exiled to France, where they wrote a new song. The people united will never be defeated.
那些爆炸声被录进了实际的广播录音中。萨尔瓦多·阿连德在发表完那次讲话后不久，于当天自杀身亡。据估计，在皮诺切特统治期间，大约有38,000人被监禁，其中大多数囚犯遭受了酷刑。近3,000人被处决。另有1,200人失踪，大约200,000人流亡到其他国家。事实上，基拉·帕云，那个创作了阿连德竞选歌曲的乐队，流亡到了其他国家。事实上，基拉·帕云（Kila Pallune），这个创作了阿连德竞选歌曲的乐队，流亡到了法国，在那里他们创作了一首新歌。团结的人民永远不会被打败。
The song became the anthem of resistance against Pinochet, and the chorus has continued to be a chant that left his protests across the world. Project Cybersen never got fully up and running. The Telex network was set up, and the system was starting to receive data from factories, but it was slow to come in. And the operations room was finished, but it hadn't really been put to use yet. Gui Bon Siepé managed to escape Chile with the one color photograph ever taken of the
这首歌成为了反抗皮诺切特的抗议赞歌，副歌也一直成为世界各地左翼抗议活动的口号。赛博信计划从未完全全面投入运行。电传打字机网络已经建立，系统也开始从工厂接收数据，但速度很慢。作战室虽然建成了，但并没有真正投入使用。吉·邦西佩设法带着作战室仅存的一张彩色照片以及与赛博信相关的各种文件逃离了智利。对我来说，这是科学与技术、政治与设计交汇的一个瞬间。这种情况并不常见，我想说。
operations room and various other documents related to Cybersen. It was for me emitting at the intersection of science and technology, politics and design. This does not happen very often, I would say. Cybersen was maybe just a bit ahead of its time. A network pieced together with telek's machines and one computer, just a couple decades before the internet made this kind of thing commonplace. In Operations Room, designed to convey information as quickly as possible, only you had to crawl behind a wall and put a new slide in the carousel when you wanted to show something to the group.
赛博信或许只是稍微超越了它的时代。一个由电传打字机和一台计算机拼凑而成的网络，比互联网让这类事情变得普遍早了仅仅几十年。在作战室里，为了尽可能快地传达信息，你却必须爬到墙后面，在想向大家展示某些东西时，把一幅新的幻灯片放进旋转盘里。
Subrison's technology was probably never up to the task at hand. But then again, it was a technology designed to help socialism succeed while the United States did everything in its power to make it fail. Maybe no technology was up to that task. Having sake at that time, we were so inspired by the possibility that it is possible to change society. When you look at the operations room, I mean, how can you not look at it and see that this is someone's dream?
赛博信的技术可能从来没有胜任过眼前的任务。但话又说回来，这是一种旨在帮助社会主义走向成功的技术，而美国却在尽其所能地让它失败。也许没有任何技术能够胜任这项任务。当时的情况是，我们对这种可能性如此着迷，觉得改变社会是有可能的。当你看着这个作战室时，我的意思是，你怎么能不看着它并看到这是某人的梦想呢？
Right? That this is someone's utopian vision. There is a kind of hope about it. When Pinachet took over Chile, he destroyed this strange futuristic space that embodied the utopian dreams of the I&D government. He had no use for such a thing. 99% invisible was produced this week by Katie Mingle, which refused to have Sam Greenspan, Kurt Colstad, A Trouffman, Emmett Fitzgerald, Terran Mazza, Delaney Hall, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to Patrick McRae, Sarah Henry, and Paul Pangaro.
对吧？这正是某人的乌托邦愿景。它带有一种希望。当皮诺切特接管智利时，他摧毁了这个体现了阿连德政府乌托邦梦想的奇怪而充满未来感的空间。他根本不需要这种东西。“99%隐形”本周由凯蒂·明格尔制作，她拒绝了萨姆·格林斯潘、库尔特·科尔斯特ッド、A·特鲁夫曼、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、泰兰·马扎、德莱尼·霍尔和我的帮助——我是罗曼·马尔斯。特别感谢帕特里克·麦克雷、萨拉·亨利和保罗·潘加罗。
Fernando Flores spent three years as a political prisoner in Chile and was eventually able to escape with the help of Anastasia International. Stafford Beer continued to lecture on cybernetics until his death in 2002. Eden Medina's book Cybernetic Revolutionaries, Technology and Politics in Iendase Chile has so many more details about cybercent. Find a link to it and see the one glorious color photograph of cybercent's operations room at our website. It's 99pi.org. We are a project of 91.7K ALW San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find this show and join the discussions about the show on Facebook.
费尔南多·弗洛雷斯在智利做过三年政治犯，最终在国际特赦组织的帮助下得以逃脱。斯塔福德·比尔继续就控制论发表演讲，直到2002年逝世。伊登·梅迪纳的书《控制论革命者：阿连德智利的技术与政治》中有关于赛博信的更多细节。请在我们的网站上查找链接，并欣赏赛博信作战室那唯一一张辉煌的彩色照片。网址是99pi.org。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，制作于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心广播街。您可以在Facebook上找到本节目并参与有关节目的讨论。
You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99pi.org. We're on Instagram and Tumblr too. But everything 99PI comes together at 99PI.org. Radio to PI. From P-R-X. Thanks. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在推特上@我，用户名是Roman Mars，也可以@节目，网址是99pi.org。我们也在Instagram和汤博乐上。但关于99PI的一切最终都会汇聚在99PI.org。来自PRX的广播。谢谢。这集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。